we go back a little bit after we look at
the 1961 World Championship match game
number 11
between Mikhail Botvinnik and they call
them chest encyclopedia because it was
so knowledgeable about the game and
there are pictures of him funny pictures
like cartoons he had like books always
with him by carrying t4 books so and his
opponent is a very different place
mikhail tall player who was a world
champion for a very short amount of time
but he was very sacrificial a lot of
fancy attacks brilliant ideas but
usually for this kind of players it's
very hard to remain at the very top so
it was good that he warned and become a
world champion because a lot of great
great players who maybe had a chance or
two to become a champion it didn't take
it and then they not remembered very
well so in chess usually if you're a
world champion you remembered really
well I mean there are some exceptions we
have like poker is so people know and
David Brownstein a lot of top players
who won but usually world champions
they're remembered for a very long time
so here in this game it's Botvinnik is
playing with white against towel d4
Knight f6 c4
now
c6
this is a pretty rare way of playing a
sloth defense but I think he was trying
to see whether or not c-4 would be
played so he was trying to see the c4
would be played and then he played the
Slav so he was trying to see if maybe
something else will happen so but now we
see it's going to be a Slav defense so
Knight c3 d5 so by a little strange move
order
we have transposed into the Slav defense
and here he decided to now he decided to
play what I play as well exchange
variation so he took back on d5 pawn
takes back see even at the world
championship level in 1961 they play
this openings because they thought there
is something they can find that each
player had a team of people who analyze
the theory so they thought they can find
something perhaps so Knight f3 knight c6
Bishop f4 Bishop f5 one of the main
lines and it looks like they are just
copying each other for the first couple
of moves but that will change
III is six I like to move Queen b3 here
that's my favorite move here move Queen
b3 to put pressure on b7 but he played
the move Bishop b5 he tried another move
to pin it Bishop b4 they'll continue but
now it's going to stop and now white to
play I want to give you a chance to play
like Botvinnik a couple of ideas here
you have you can of course castle you
can do some other things but what do you
think he played here he is looking to
get some small advantage and try to you
know squeeze
and win this game so Todd was very good
in dynamic position so here by doing
this exchange violation he takes away
that dynamic play and basically kind of
forces tile to go into some quiet boring
position to play yeah now you don't want
to play Knight Edgeville right now you
only blown a plane I teach Ford if you
have a way of force winning the bishop
if the Queen's are after board that's a
kind of atom attic idea you can do that
but here's not quite so any other
suggestions
yes like I mentioned in the previous
lecture night belongs where in the
center right in the center and there's
clear you want to do that activating
your knight and putting pressure very
good now tau of course playing very
active again Queen to a5 activating
threatening to take the light square
Bishop putting pressure on c3 now
question is what to do castle
that's a possibility but he decided to
take the knight with a check create a
weak pawn and then go for safety
remember safety of the pink King is your
number one priority when you play chess
okay so that's your number one priority
so remember that to castle now after we
castle the c6 is hanging so I decided to
take on c3 pawn takes c3
and now just quintics III black is up
upon but his King is stuck in the middle
of the board but do we have a way do we
have some some idea perhaps to keep the
King there for a while what do you think
that's a possibility but after you play
rook c1 he just goes here and your pawn
is weak again on a 2 now very special
move needed here very very special play
I want from you here when a for
excellent suggestion a very good-looking
move yeah but he did not play that he
did not want to do that he not sure why
he didn't play Queen a4 it looks
absolutely fine but I can only think
that maybe he didn't want to deal with
Queen c2 something like that ok
right next
castle right next to the Queen you want
to put it here here put it here well we
want to attack the Queen here
well let's try to exchange the coins
maybe
yes Quincy one excellent that's what you
play because now you force the exchange
take well yeah we don't where we don't
want to move a rook here because we want
to yeah if we move the rook here it
doesn't really do anything so that's why
like it's kind of locked so but Quincy
won after we take now our look is in the
game
okay so castle now excellent move by
Botvinnik see it looks like he can just
take the pawn on c6 but he's not in
hurry to do that h3 looked at a look but
it's a he does a little better loft that
helps them to control some more squares
excellent suggestion that would but
Vinick did after a getting a lift
possibilities to push and control
control the squares right excellent h6
and now
not yet not yet let's get the material
back because we don't want to play down
a pawn yeah
so take a pawn back 96 rook f e8 now I
want you to spend two three minutes
everyone here and try to give me the
proper evaluation of this position what
is the proper evaluation here it looks
kind of equal now same amount of
material very similar structure so give
me an idea why is white Oh first of all
do you think white is better here who
thinks white is better okay reasons
okay that's true yeah we are mainly
better here because we have a more
active night here okay and our Bishop is
I mean his bishop is doing a pretty
decent job as well but our Knight is the
main reason we are better here at night
is more active okay and it's already
targeting this pawn but who can find
what boo Clinic played here he had a
nice long-term plan you know and this
move makes ton of ton of sense here and
it's just it's a very clear what he is
trying to do here he is trying to win
the a pawn and win this game and you
will see that he accomplished that but
you take you need to do certain steps
for that to happen because you're not
going to be able to do that like that
Ben then look at my light square bishop
look at my light square bishop see it
now that's not so simple yes if we had
root P 1 or P 7 then it would have been
simple that's not possible but he wants
to do something Bravo Bravo that is both
we Nick move right - because you're
pushing your pawn so when you win his
pan your pawn is closer to Queen and
most importantly look at this ideas
because that's where you want your rook
rooks belong we're in the endgame 7th
rank and that's what is accomplishing
that's both winning play right there
a4 rooks belong on the seventh ranked
rooks a good place for the rock yeah
that's seventh rank okay now it goes
here 97 and now strong move here again
by Bar Tonique to squeeze
he wants that Bishop Bishop wants to get
more active now you want Bishop active
now of course Bishop d6 come see now you
want to check and take the bishop damage
the structure okay damage did 9 was 96
he wants to plant his knight here and
that could be a problem because we're
not gonna be able to remove him so we
want to win some material before that
happens okay before that happens we want
to try to somehow snatch some material
now we should be six headed deep idea
behind it he didn't just play the move
there was an idea behind it and you will
see it now
excellent when you choose a plan you
stick with it right
the a7 pawn is weak and you stick with
that plan now you can now move your
knight away because you're going to lose
the pawn he's putting serious pressure
on it now Bishop d3 black is trying to
activate his own Bishop if you push the
pan it's going to crow back on c8 and
try to defend somehow so it's going to
try to go back and see it and try to
defend
something better you have something
stronger here tactics yes Claudia Knight
takes a seven excellent tactic
sacrificing the night he takes back we
take the night and now you have a strong
pawn here and this is called passed pawn
outside pass pawn actually passed pawn
yes now he goes here and this passed
pawn now advances and strengthens the
position of that Bishop but tal had an
idea he that maybe can hold this not
easy to win this how are you going to
win this it's locked it's opposite
collar bishops and it's locked now but
master Owen games both Finnick found a
gap you know in the position and convert
this very convincingly actually very
convincingly be shipped human here
that's c7 but let's say he will bring
the rock over
see
let's see this this this takes check
okay okay well let's don't rush
yes that's the long-term plan here
but what Botvinnik that he likes to do
he likes to get the rook into the game
for so he goes here up efore it's his
plan it's not going to run away then he
plays efore king f7 now now when you
play chess in end games King belongs
where in the end game in the middle
right look what he does he brings it in
you know like a piece he brings it in
you know and this is very important okay
eight King III now he says my King was
the King to be participant as well now
rook eb8 now do you see now what is he
threatening after he plays this move I
should see more hands by now war it's
black threatening in the back let's say
you play the poor move here b6 look at
the tactic takes your bishop you take
back lose your rook with the check and
then guess what
lose the pan as well afterwards see you
can play a good game here but one
inaccurate play one you know one moment
of not focus and you're going to lose
this game and that's what chess is all
about focus focus focus you have to
focus for the entire game here otherwise
you're not going to be able to play a
good game and way because you will make
a mistake so you must focus now so how
we avoid this tactical threat
look look ACA correct
now look c8 because in some point your
position is so good you might even
sacrifice the exchanger because you
might have dominating position so he
stops that I'm very impressed the way
that he crapped this position because
this position is not easy to win
I am telling even GM vs. GM matchups a
lot of GM's not going to be able to win
this this is not an easy position to win
at the very high level because yes you
have extra pound yes you have a great
Bishop rooks are fine but plan you need
a plan here it's it's not obvious at all
here how are you going to win this so
how this is the plan you need to create
a second weakness okay you have that one
pawn there but there is no weakness
anymore in a blacks position so you want
to create a weakness okay
let's not rush let's not rush okay
we don't want to weaken our light
squares by pushing the f1 because he
will play a five also and in general you
don't want to weaken your light squares
if you don't have a light square Bishop
light square Bishop yeah so more pants
you put on a dark square that means
you're weakening your light squares so
who can find both Phoenix plan here I
need a plan I don't need the move I need
a I need a plan from you here
if he has that rustic based on a king a
queen side challenge in
go go where kingside
excellent excellent thinking again Brian
very impressive excellent now he starts
with G for first okay that gains space
very strong G for push rook a b-1 and h4
look at that gaining space the concept
is to gain some space that would be very
useful later in the game so as you can
see he has no black cannot do much so he
just shuffles around he goes fixing it
okay on h5 now he goes here what is the
plan now though he is resilient
he is resilient yes whoo-hoo black
played G Phi where where here h g5 a
page h5 your h6 one will be week forever
and in a lot of positions you will drop
this pawn okay so this you don't want to
avoid because this pawn is very weak
okay
so later I mean I don't have an
immediate win here to show you but this
this is a very weak pawn that's why your
king can never go away because my bishop
is going boom boom
take your pond this is a very weak pawn
now okay I can probably even win without
rooks now because my king will go there
and your King cannot go because I have
this pawn I mean just just an idea okay
so that's why I mean this this is not
bad for block this is I mean it's not so
easy to win this they're like again I'm
not I'm not saying it's immediate win
here it's tricky now what to do here
f/4g five too many exchanges called your
too many exchanges there something
better and plus cloud uf4 i take your
palm yeah but then Bishop d5 I don't
know
so you were Pontic defy not so don't
want to exchange now I want more space
from you more space advantage that means
advancing your pants into opponent's
territory controlling the squares that
he is supposed to control excellent see
this is his side of the world you're
coming in into his territory and you
grabbing squares that's called gaining
space advantage okay in space it's very
important now if it takes you take back
with a pawn then your king can sit very
nicely here and then you can either f4
f5 plan I like this move so if they g6
blocked as I want to just get you know
completely squeezed so he wants to break
up and I don't know this is a good move
or not but that's what he played so
takes takes now he goes here
Brooke 3 c2 Fe Fe rook h8 now he's
anticipating some problems here and now
need to put pressure on h6 ok he wants
to put pressure that's why he brought
the rook on c2 to be able to put
pressure
very clear thinking gasps Brooke eh -
Brooke cc8 now not yet not yet
your king needs to be improved a little
bit
he paid d to actually because he wants
to have this access access for the
bishop okay don't block the access we
should be too now I don't know what
McHale tall did I mean I'm not sure I
think he played an inaccurate move here
and he was just but his position is bad
here but I think what he did is just
kind of expedited the process here
because he for some reason moved the
bishop when you move the bishop who is
protecting this guy now nobody run get
closer to the Queen run now he went back
here this didn't I didn't understand
this I think this was just like he got
tired and just blundered or something
because he just allowed the opponent to
have a part on a seventh rank maybe was
hoping to sacrifice his exchange or
something so Luke h7 rook over rook e8
stopping it and now this is the target
what are you going to do to the target
Bishop h6 put a pressure on it excellent
by Botvinnik now you should be three
putting pressure on this and now he can
double it up and cleanly take the pawn
okay towel didn't resign he played a
couple of more moves so but check rook
h1 rugby to check I think P either
flagged or resigned here but after king
c1 is completely lost here so if it goes
back here check if it goes back round
then it's a check picking up the rook
and if it comes here you see the
checkmate there excellent so that's the
game okay both Finnick Mikhail Botvinnik
this is mikhail tau 1961 and this was a
24th world championship match and game
number 11
yeah so both Vinick won this game and I
think it was pretty convincing in this
match as well all right any questions
you have about this game this was a
sloth defense opening exchange variation
okay what we'll do now is the remaining
little time we have left we're going to
do a couple of difficult and game
studies and see how good you are in
solving this end game studies let's see
why to play and win down a queen you win
this very difficult end game study to
find you have to go really deep in this
position to find the solution white
start and find in wins this game I don't
use engines to solve this but III think
the current interest will probably solve
this quickly because just so powerful
excellent correct
okay then sold it guys okay he knew this
he he knew this one okay don't show the
answer let everybody to do it
okay we have to find a first move here
okay it's got to be a check that's good
logic right there yes it's got to be a
check how many checks you see here not
too many right now if I check now if he
goes here Bravo Bravo
but this is I played not good for block
that's why now I go here this is the
real stuff now now
this is where you need to play brilliant
okay you need to play extraordinary now
it needs to be something extraordinary
here
we need something extraordinary here not
something irregular we should be to
check King the tree and he's escaping
from danger he is escaping from the
danger see the danger is on the Kings
side and the Queen side here this is the
danger area right here I know but he
goes King he - yeah that's that's a good
good call it you know you Brian was
saying check check up sorry check this
is beautiful yes but unfortunately he
escapes here and and then get way is out
of danger okay so here brilliant move
needed here double exclamation mark here
you move imagine it's double exclam here
check but I go here you'd let your let
you pushing me from the danger zone you
know you're pushing me away from the
danger zone here
and care Rock T for now I take your
Bishop when calculate calculate
awkwardly folio calculate
excellent plant by Claudio check if he
takes what do you do look at that one
look at that scuba huh
what's kubera look at that school can I
go to this course to protect the Queen
so he has to step away snap it off how
many people in this room know how to win
this position okay okay one day one of
these days while I'm here we'll work on
this this is a pretty this will take a
whole lesson okay but this is a really
good end game if we have some end game
lecture time we'll do that okay this is
the you know you I will show you how to
master this and if takes with this
obviously fork wins this but Claudia did
you look at this move ah guys check
everything remember everything checkmate
love you absolutely you should continue
from here on correct he takes
of course same idea guys same idea
you forgot III check and we obtained
this position excellent now let's do it
again so everybody here will remember
this
okay well we'll do it again you will see
it now okay who wants to go okay
Benjamin first move this leads to a mate
right now what's the move
yes brilliant move brilliancy he takes
check wins it
so it was Queen G it is trying to be
resilient you know resilient now what
are you going to do
rock-beetle check he takes we should be
to check and now King has to go away and
we take the Queen at night and a bishop
is a win okay
very good everyone so we cover the 1961
Botvinnik versus towel a nice endgame
win in a Slavic change variation by
Botvinnik and this was a very important
nice win for him I really like where you
know from almost equal position he
managed to squeeze improve his pieces
and find a nice weekend at the end of
the class you had a very difficult study
so more coming up next week okay for you